قال البيت الابيض ان الاداره الامريكيه
قامت بتعليق التمويل المخصص لوكاله الاونر
ولم تقم بانهاء من جهته قال وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انتوني بلينكن ان الامم المتحده
تظل شريكا محوريا لكن يجب معالجه المزاعم
الفظيعه التي اثيرت بحق بعض موظفي
الاونروا وفق تعبيره تصريحات بلينكن جاءت
قبيل اجتماعه مع المنسقه الامميه
للمساعدات في غزه سريد كاغ في
واشنطن
[موسيقى]
سنعمل بشكل وثيق للغايه مع سيجريد
واسرائيل ومصر والاطراف المعنيه لمضاعفه
المساعدات التي تصل الى غزه لايصالها
للاشخاص الذين يحتاجون اليها داخل القطاع
بما في ذلك الشمال يتعين علينا ان نعمل
على حل المزاعم الرهيبه التي اثيرت فيما
يتعلق ببعض موظف الاونور ونتطلع الى ان
يتم القيام بالعمل اللازم لمعالجه هذا
الوضع personnel